i
you know the two things that i know
about in this world uh
is skateboarding and and drugs and
alcohol like that's kind of what i i
know and i love the most and dude by the
way you are [ __ ] skateboarding dude
i'm so impressed by the the
video you showed me before
again and i'm not trying to suck you off
live on this show but seeing the clips
that you send me and i'm like dude this
is because when i got sober i wanted no
part of skateboarding because i felt
like it was the love that i let get away
have you surpassed a younger you yeah
i'm
excited that's been my goal like like in
my i was like man in my 40s if i can out
skate every younger version of me that's
yeah that's i mean i have a video part
coming out that is by far the best part
i've ever put out at 42. right right i'm
still learning tricks um
i'm in the best shape i've ever been in
like physically but we have to fight so
hard to get a trick i saw your post the
other day when you slam that kick flip
i could relate to like i saw in your
face i'm so sure yeah
i need a walker for like five days after
i skate
it's not it's tough it's a lot i can't
flip the board much these days
um
steve have you surpassed the old school
like
i
there are certain things
that i just will never be able to do
again that i could do it at a certain
time you know
but
what i've been going after and like when
i try to get a new trick it's such a
battle but the tricks that i have gotten
are things that i have never done before
or are like way bigger versions of
something i've done before so like i i
have outskated myself but
leaving out a bunch of stuff that i
could never do that i could do before i
noticed that i i start really um
kind of talking myself out of things
that i could probably do like oh well
it's pretty dicey i could get hurt where
before that was never the mind frame it
was yeah
do first think last now i'm kind of
being really cautious overly maybe
and
[Laughter]
that's so funny we can like keep a tally
for those before we start recording
steve
and i just did that again i have coughed
towards you every time in your life
that is on the podcast okay
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude